من فضيحه الى مطب ومما طب الى فضيحه هذا
حال الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
الذي تعرضت اعماله في الوصول الى البيت
الابيض لولايه ثانيه لضربه قويه
وترام كان يراهن على مد المحافظين في
الانتخابات النصفيه لكنه تعثر مع سقوطه
عدد غير قليل من مرشحين
الانتكاسه وحملت سلسله ردات اهتزازيه دفعت
شخصيات المحافظه من العيار الثقيل الى
التخلي عنه محمله ترامب مسؤوليه الهزيمه
لكن ترامب المثيره للجدل احتفظ بمفاجاه
سيئه اخرى عشان مع مغني الراب كان يوست
المتهم بمعاداه الساميه
لانقاص من الانتقادات الجمهوريه من عيار
مثير للسخريه
عكست حجم الاستياء داخل المعسكر الجمهوريه
ولمن اعتقد ان متاعب الرئيس الخامس
والاربعين للولايات المتحده انتهت اخرج
ترامب من جعبته مفاجاه سيئه ثالثه او
رابعه
اتهامات التزوير الانتخابي خطاب واتهامات
باتت شخصيات ثقيله في الحزب الجمهوري
بنفسها عنها ليس هي فحسب ايضا هناك عدد
كبير من كبار منحيه احجم عن دعم ترجيحه في
تاثير بدا واضحا على ترامب الذي يراهن
مؤيدوه على مفاجاه قد تقلب الامور لصالحه
واجبر الرئيس السابق على احجام عن اي تجمع
انتخابي خارجه مقر اقامته في مره لاجوبي
ولايه فلوريدا منذ ان اعلن ترشحه اذا
متعبه سياسيه ترافقها ايضا اخرى ماليه مع
خضوع ترامب لعدد من التحقيقات حول اداره
ارشفه وكذلك في شؤونه الماليه في نيويورك